les vestiges de lusine présente semble
complexe dont la lecture est rendue
difficile il part les nombreuses
modifications opérées au cours du temps
outre la cheminée de section carrée on
distingue trois bâtiments principaux où
se déroulaient les grandes étapes de la
production à savoir le broyage des
cannes le traitement par cuisson du jus
extrait jusqu'à sa cristallisation la
récupération des égouts notamment de la
mélasse le grand bassin massonnet située
à l'est de lusine permettait d'alimenter
les moulins à vapeur les bassins peu
profond situé au sud délimité par des
murets assurer le refroidissement de
l'eau produite par le générateur
l'ensemble des constructions révèle des
maçonneries de moellons et de pierres de
taille la brique est utilisé pour des
entourages des paies pour les parties
soumises ou phlx des maçonneries sont en
général enduite d'un mortier de chaux et
sable basaltiques parfois badigeonnait
le réemploi de matériaux et général
pierre de taille mais les hauts murs de
galets briques réfractaires mêmes pièces
mécaniques utilisés en bouchage